une fête de la violette qui a pris des
airs de meeting d'Eric Zemmour samedi à
Pierrefitte-sur-Sauldre la septième
édition de cet événement organisée
depuis 10 ans par Guillaume Pelletier se
déroulait pour la première fois sous la
bannière de reconquête particules
l'ancien député du Loir-et-Cher a
rejoint en 2022 2500 sympathisants
étaient présents l'objectif du parti
mobilisé pour les élections européennes
de 2024 avec pour ennemi désigné
l'immigration le walkisme et
l'assistanat reportage de Florent Clavel
[Applaudissements]
à
la suite
Pelletier mais aussi Marion maréchal et
Nicolas Bay les trois vices présidents
du parti reconquête comme honte celui
que les 2500 sympathisants attendent
Éric Zemmour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'homme aux 7% la présidentielle tape
fort et vite sur son thème de
prédilection l'immigration tout en
rejetant l'étiquette de leader d'extrême
droite pour celle de la droite
authentique c'est-à-dire une droite
civilisationnelle qui défend la
civilisation française qui dépend
l'identité française qui lutte pour le
mérite les pores à l'école vous voyez
qu'il lutte contre l'idéologie wok c'est
son rôle
un discours destiné à galvaniser les
troupes en vue de 2024 après l'échec des
4% législatives
Eric Zemmour vise désormais les
européennes avec de hautes ambitions en
croire les militants on doit pouvoir
faire entre 12 et 20%
et donc un vrai score pour la droite
avec cette question encore en suspend
avant la fête de la violette quelle
place pour Guillaume Pelletier désormais
simple conseiller départemental de
Loir-et-Cher l'ancien député à lui-même
mis fin au spéculation on a deux
excellentes tête de liste potentiel le
président de notre parti qui a mené
l'épopée présidentielle Éric Zemmour et
puis Marion avec laquelle on travaille
beaucoup donc ça se passe très très bien
entre nous et on va faire surtout équipe
ensemble un meeting qui s'est déroulé
dans de bonnes conditions après les
violences à Brest le préfet avait mis en
place un important dispositif de
sécurité avec plusieurs contrôles de
gendarmerie les 150 opposants avaient
tout choisi volontairement de ne pas en
découdre ce cantonnant dans le village à
environ un kilomètre du meeting